hello and thank you for joining us today
for our next presentation
my name is david ferrick and i'm the
associate vice president for cell
analysis at agilent
and i'll be your host for this
presentation i hope
you've all been enjoying the
presentations and virtual events uh of
our first 24-hour ever
digital event focused on immunology and
cancer biology we're really excited and
we already know that a number of you've
seen great presentations from people
like ping chi ho
and uh christopher direnzo laura campa
hanbo chi and a number of others and
just really
excited to be able to share those with
you
this next speaker i actually have the
privilege of the next talk
um which is entitled linking cancer
metabolism due
to neurodegeneration uh by none other
than dr navdeep chandelle who is the the
david w
coogle uh professor of medicine and
biochemistry and molecular genetics at
northwestern
uh nav uh has been a leader in the field
of
mitochondria for for many many years uh
what i believe has separated his work
for many of what we call mitochondria
those individuals that are uniquely
focused
on this amazing organelle is really the
ability to connect it to biology through
signaling
and really give it a presence in the
world
of biology and disease investigation
and really uniquely through the lens of
the mitochondria itself
making it much much more than a
biochemical wonder
so i'm really just excited to have nav
here today and in fact
sharing a new perspective uh
with neurodegeneration and all that
we've learned in cancer metabolism so
before i hand it over to nav
just a couple of quick housekeeping
notes there is a q a
period immediately following nas talk
and help us get to as many of your
questions as possible we encourage
that you type in your questions during
the presentation so that we can
facilitate that process better and with
that naf
take it away and thank you for attending
great david i'm delighted to be here and
thank you again for the kind invite
um i'm excited to tell you some of our
ongoing work in cancer metabolism
and how it links to neurodegeneration
and so uh
just to uh orient everybody i
let me see if i make sure get my slides
up
uh here's my disclosure slide and so
i always show this slide um because it
reminds
everybody of what the textbooks tell you
about what mitochondria functionally do
and the key here is
their function right and um if you read
any biochemistry book or
a cheap plug here you can buy my own
book navigating metabolism
we know that mitochondria generate atp
right the process of oxidative
phosphorylation
now equally important is a recognition
that the great biochemists
discovered in the 20th century that
mitochondria
also generate these metabolites and
these metabolites are
essentially sort of the building blocks
for growth right so you can just go back
to your biochemistry books
and for example citrate is the backbone
for lipogenesis or oxaloacetate
eventually can funnel into aspartate
for nucleotide synthesis succeed
so the canonical functions of
mitochondria tend to be
its role in bioenergetics and as well as
biosynthetic organelles and this has
been widely appreciated now for many
decades
one of the excitements in the field i
would say really in the last 25 years
and this is where largely our work has
contributed to
is what is call the third essential
function of mitochondria which is
their role as signaling organelles in
other words mitochondria are responding
to
environmental inputs or changes in the
cytoplasm and
by responding to either changes in
nutrients or
oncogenes they themselves release
signaling molecules and these signaling
molecules then
can make pivotal decisions in the cell
uh biology
so uh we were inspired by uh zhaodong
wong's spectacular finding that
mitochondria released cytochrome c
to make a decision for cell death by
activating caspases
and we followed this work in the late
90s by uh
mid to late 90s by discovering that h202
can be released by mitochondria
for the activation of hiftopen and gene
expression
recently our work has led to
depreciation the tca cycle metabolized
through changes in chromatin
modification or dna methylation can
impact cell fate or function obviously
there's quite a bit of work
and excitement around mitochondrial dna
being released to
modulate inflammation as well as you
know atp still matters so mitochondria
have changes in atp
uh concentrations and you can activate
ampk and that will actually
uh shut down anabolic functions in the
cell and change to a catabolic program
and so these are just
give you some ideas about how
mitochondria are signaling now
these are not the only ways i think
there are more and more
things being discovered almost weekly
and how mitochondria is signaling and i
think this is quite an exciting area
especially for the younger generation to
sort of
get into there a lot to be discovered
here i'll just give you two
salient examples of mitochondrial
signaling one comes from
some of our work in hif as many of you
know
the regulation of hypoxia inducible
factor
was given the nobel prize this past year
and we know under normoxia this
protein is hydroxylated by proline
hydroxylases the phds
and that hydroxylation is recognized by
the vhl protein which brings in this e3
ligase activity and degrades
if alpha subunit but mitochondria can
release
hydrogen peroxide as well as tca cycle
metabolites that will prevent that
hydroxylation
and under hypoxia this will then cause
stabilization of the heath alpha subunit
which they can then bind to hyphen beta
and turn on a variety of genes involved
in erythropoiesis androgenesis tumor
evasion
metabolism genes uh as well as immune
a response idea that we like to work on
is how tca cycle metabolites change the
epigenetic landscape
you know as uh in the last 25 years the
epigenetic communities discovered many
enzymes that control chromatin
modification or dna
methylation or demethylation has been an
appreciation that many of these enzymes
use uh metabolic substrates from the tca
cycle so for example
a histone acetylation you needed acetyl
co group and in part
that acetyl co group comes from citrate
so citric can exit the mitochondria
where atp citric lys
will uh generate acetyl coa and that'll
make
that will be used for histone
acetylation many of the d
methylase reactions so both for rna dna
and histones
are alpha-ketoglutarate-dependent uh
family members
and if you have more succinate form rate
or l-2-hydroxide glutamate and we'll
talk about this later
compared to alpha-ketoglutarate then you
can inhibit those d-methylases and
you'll get a hypermethylation of
histones
dna as well as rna and so you can see
how mitochondria
early in evolution were communicating
potentially through these metabolites
uh to change gene expression and cell
fade and function
so my lab is interested in four areas
we've done a lot of work in the cancer
arena which i'll
talk about and i'll show you how that's
led to our recent appreciation in
neurodegeneration
uh another theme has been aging uh
because again mitochondria are quite
related to the
aging as well as uh inflammation and you
probably have heard
already from other speakers about how
metabolism can control
immune function i won't touch upon some
of that data today
just briefly mention it but i really
want to talk about our most recent story
that recently got published on cancer
and then
a new story on how it's linked to near
degeneration
so we got into the field of cancer
metabolism almost
13 14 years ago now when a talented
graduate student frank weinberg insisted
that we work on cancer metabolism but in
vivo and i said well you know there's a
simple
experiment we could do to test the role
the necessity of
the electron transport chain uh for
tumor growth
and uh that's we can take advantage of a
protein called t-fam
which is necessary for mitochondrial dna
and replication so if you lose t-fam
mitochondrial dna is lost and a whole
bunch of
complexes sort of fall apart because
remember the mitochondrial dna encodes
for a few subunits
of these critical electron transport
chain subunits
and so no t fan no electron transport
it's almost a hammer experiment
and now your cancer cells are purely
glycolytic right
right so these are highly glycolytic
tumors and we asked whether
in vivo whether you get a bigger tumor
or a smaller tumor and what frank did
was he crossed our t-fenflox mice to
uh the k-ras oncogenic
uh mice and basically these what you can
do is you can add creed down the lungs
of the mice and activate conditionally
oncogenic
kras g12d and
at the same time you can flux out the t
fam gene so wherever the keras gene is
activated
you lose t-fam and you can ask a couple
of weeks later 10 weeks later 12 weeks
later whether
the tumor burden is less us the same
or much bigger so remember they are
purely glycolytic and many people would
have predicted because these are now
sort of classic warbird-like cells in
other words
as showing higher rates of aerobic
glycolysis that maybe you would get
bigger tumors in fact we got
much smaller tumors so again this is in
a system where you have an intact
immune system it's in the right location
in the lung
and is being driven by a known oncogene
that drives lung adenocarcinoma and i
think
many uh laboratories have uh repeated uh
a version of this sort of experiment in
the past 10 12 years
have come to the same conclusion that in
vivo if you knock out
the respiratory chain pharmacologically
or genetically you have
less tumors not typically bigger tumors
so uh recently a couple of years ago in
martinez reyes
a talented postdoc who left the lab
recently
uh was interested in asking so what's so
special about the electron transport
chain like why do you need it for tumor
growth
so what metabolic requirements are
linked to the mitochondrial respiratory
chain for tumor growth
and so the system that she
chose to work on is uh looking at
tumor cells that where she can make them
deficient in electron transport chain
complex three so hair is highlighted in
blue
and the idea was we'll just knock out
electron transport chain
uh by knocking out now not the whole
chain but specifically mitochondrial
complex three
and presumably they'll make less tumors
and then we can try to
go back and do simple add back
experiments and you'll see what i mean
in a second and to figure out what about
a low electron transport chain is
necessary so we needed
to sort of do this in a few models and
i'll show you these models in a second
so one of the models we did is a
notch-driven oncogenic notch-driven
leukemic
model so in this model basically what
we're doing
is we're taking hematopoietic stem cells
and
we uh make them leukemic by giving notch
and we give them to bone marrow uh
irradiate bone marrows uh and then after
we let the
the tumor cells engraft and start to
grow a little bit and then we give them
tamoxifen what the tamoxifen allows us
to do
is to knock out complex three subunit
called qpc it's one of the
uh the key subunits of complex three so
you knock out qpc
in these leukemic cells uh you lose
electron transport chain function you
lose mitochondrial complex three
and in the spleen and the bone marrow
you have a lot less cells it's quite
dramatic right
and this was sort of expected but it was
nice again this is a real bona fide
tumor genesis model uh that shows that
indeed complex three is essential for
tumor progression
we can take uh kras g12d
oncogenic transformed lung
adenocarcinoma cells which also harbor
uh loss of p53 again these are the two
main drivers
of many lung adenocarcinomas again we
can buy crispr knockout in this case
complex three
and again you get markedly less tumors
and the mice survive and so again
just another model and finally sort of a
workhorse cell line
is a human osteosarcoma cell line and so
this is a human cell line which harbors
a mutation
in this and again an essential subunit
of complex three called
cytochrome b and in vitro these cells
can grow
because and we've used them for years we
give them lots of high glucose glutamine
pyruvate uridine
we give it a lot of stuff and they do
fine in vitro but in vivo clearly
they don't make any tumors so now we
have almost three different models
uh this is consistent with a lot of our
other work if you inhibit the electron
transport
uh in this case we're doing it
genetically by complex three
you barely get any tumor so the question
is why what's so special
and so going back to complex three
and here's a simple schematic we wanted
to know
is there something special about complex
three so we know what does complex three
really do well like proton pumps the
proton pumping is
contributes to atp generation right this
is oxidative phosphorylation
but the other thing that it really does
is it takes electrons from ubiquinol
so just to remind you of the
biochemistry there's upstream complexes
complex one and two
remember complex one regenerates nad
complex two regenerates fad
those regeneration of nad and fad allows
the tca cycle to go round and round so
you can generate all those metabolites
for growth
uh a rate-leading rate-limiting enzyme
for primitive nucleotides is d-h-o-d-h
uh interestingly it's the only
nucleotide enzyme
that's stuck in the in the mitochondria
uh it
also donates two electrons to ubiquinone
so complex one
two and dh or dh all donate two
electrons to ubiquinone or q
and by donating getting those two
electrons ubiquinone becomes reduced to
ubiquinol
and then ubiquinol passes its electrons
to complex three
and in turns regenerates to become uh q
again ubiquinone
and by regenerating q you can now dump
in
two more electrons from these upstream
complexes so really
a major role of complex three is to
continue to
recycle electrons so you can continue to
have the upstream complexes function
so we ask is is there something special
about this this taking electrons from q
or is it something about proton pumping
and and this is where i think uh
you know here's a plug for sea horse and
agilent
this is where doing a simple sea horse
assay is really beneficial because we
know complex three knockout cells don't
respire
right so if you want to do any
manipulations back
you want to at least know what the
respiratory chain is doing and one of
its function is obviously
respiration oxygen consumption and these
cells complex three knockouts
as predicted to have barely any oxygen
consumption or coupled respiration
so now we do a genetic trick we come
back and we add back
alternative oxidase alternative oxidase
as one of these enzymes found in plants
and lower organisms and this is from c
squared
a bottom dweller right in the ocean
right and
basically a ox will take electrons from
q
just like complex three will do but
it'll donate it directly to oxygen
as the final electron acceptor what's
uh very important here is that a ox
does not generate atp right it doesn't
proton pump
in any way so it doesn't contribute to
atp production
and so when you have the schematic
basically complex one proton pumps a
little bit
and it generates atp through uh
that proton pumping of complex one but
the key thing is
ax allows for complex 1 2 and dh or dh
to function now if the main role of
complex 3 was proton pumping
we wouldn't get the tumors back but if
it's simply to allow
complex 1 2 or dh or dh to work then the
tumor should come back
so again this is where doing a simple
sea horse analysis happens
because if i just go back ax should
allow
electrons from ubiquinol and donate them
to oxygen and and therefore aiox
consumes oxygen and indeed
that's what you can see with basal
oxygen consumption
and uh you see a recovery of oxygen
consumption
the other key thing is because i just go
back complex one
generates uh proton pumps
uh it allows for generation of atp and
again coupled
o car is basically coupled respiration
so the amount of respiration is coupled
to atp generation and that also comes
back and this is all being driven by
complex one proton pumping so you bring
back atp
generation you bring back oxygen
consumption
you bring break up complex 1 2 and dh or
d
function and the tumors come back right
so it's
what it really tells you is there's
nothing special about complex three
in these tumor cells it's just simply
you can substitute another protein
that'll take electrons from
um ubiquinol and keep the upstream
complexes working
right so that's sort of the take-home
messages so now that we have a system
this sort of mini uh respiratory chain
that we've
genetically engineered where
we've gotten rid of complex 3 and put
back a ox
we can ask well are the upstream
complexes important so for example we
can ask whether
complex 2 is necessary so what we do
here is basically
take our cells which have a ox in them
and knock out complex two
oh and now these cells else don't make
tumors
right we can do the same thing with dh
or dh and again you'll find the same
result i'm not showing you but i really
want to
harbor a little bit on complex one
because it regenerates nad
and a lot of people have been interested
in nad regeneration
so we knock out complex one in the
system
again uh you don't get tumors so clearly
complex one is necessary for tumor
genesis
the real question was why right
uh what what's so special about complex
one again
is it the proton pumping maybe remember
in this in this uh system where we have
complex three laws we've put back aiox
complex one is regenerating nad but it's
also contributing to
the atp production so maybe it's the atp
that's dominant and
not dnad regeneration so again we can do
reductionist experiments we can get
rid of complex one so you get rid of
tumor growth but you've gotten rid of
both nad regeneration
as well as proton pumping and now
in this system we can add back enzymes
that
only regenerate nad right and these are
these enzymes called lb nox
ox and you can put albinox which will
regenerate nad
again they do not contribute to atp
and we can put back the lb nox which
will regenerate nad in the mitochondria
or in the cytoplasm and as you can see
it raises
the total cytoplasmic ratio
of nad2nadh so these enzymes work really
magnificently and so the real question
was what would happen to the tumors
that's right and and
what we got was basically that if we put
the nad regeneration back into the
mitochondria
right so what we do we're doing here is
we knock out complex one so by knocking
out complex one nad regeneration is gone
as is the ability to generate atp
they're both gone but if we just bring
back
nad regeneration in the mitochondria
we bring back tumor growth right
so these tumors that are growing in the
lb knots mito
that you can see those tumors they're
growing fine
right they grow as well as wild type
tumors do
right so in that system all we've
brought back is the nad regeneration and
not the atp production
so because they have a ox which doesn't
generate atp so we have a system
basically that generates
no atp from mitochondria and yet as long
as
they can regenerate nad and complex
three works
aox works they grow fine the cytoplasmic
albinox
also grows but much much much less
efficiently and the question was why
what's so what's the big difference
because they're both
nad regenerating but they're doing them
in different locations one's doing it in
the mitochondria
and what's doing in the cytoplasm and so
here
we did carbon labeling and what we did
is we
followed the labeling of glutamine that
you can see
a and the key here is that glutamine
and will label alpha ketoglutarate and
if it goes in the oxidative
clockwise direction then if you label
with heavy carbon all five carbons the
citrate pool will be
m plus four if it goes back it's called
reductive carboxylation
you get a citrix pool of m plus five
right and that's so one is the oxidative
mode
where you get m plus four one is the
reductive mode which is not an
efficient way but nevertheless it can
happen it's not as thermodynamically
favored
obviously and uh and that's the
reductive
and so when you look at the difference
of m plus four
you can see which is the oxidative the
mitochondrial nad
in those cells regeneration supports the
tca cycle going in its normal direction
and and if you sorry if you look at
the m plus five it's the either the wild
type or the
uh cytoplasmic nad regeneration enzyme
cyto cyto lb nox so the really the big
difference between the mito lb
nox or the mito nad regeneration and
cyto ned regeneration the complex one
knockouts
is that the mitochondrial led
regeneration allows for the tca cycle to
go round and round clockwise and the
oxidative mode
while the other one and the cytoplasmic
nad regeneration allows
as a reductive carboxylation to occur
and that
that can allow you to grow a bit but
clearly not very efficiently and that's
manifested here
again in the in the tumor growth you can
see they're just not very efficient
using this reductive mode of growing
though the canonical oxidative mode is
is really the preferred choice here
and so uh really uh the take-home
message
is for us is that you know the the major
role of the electron transport chain is
to keep complex 1 2 and dh or dh
from functioning and complex 1 and 2
functioning allows the tca cycle
to go round and round and it's natural
oxidative clockwise and this allows for
rapid generation of all those
metabolites
that i talked about in my first slide uh
you know aspartate for nucleotide
synthesis or citrate for lipogenesis
is and it's really the heart of it is a
ubiquinone
taking multiple as really an electron
acceptor for a
complex one complex two dh or dh
and of course as as a ubiquinone takes
all those electrons it passes off the
complex three so it can continue
the take those electrons and keep those
upstream complexes working
and so i want to just i didn't talk
anything about glycolysis or the warburg
effect which i think is universally
appreciated by
most people i want to basically make
one salient point as a take-home our
data in no way says that the warbrick
effect doesn't happen or isn't important
the way we like to think about him and
ralph debordin as
many of you know in the field and i
wrote a little commentary in nature
metabolism recently about this which is
that you know
if you just go back and think about what
is a a
anabolic metabolism looks like and this
would apply for t
cells as well or any pro-growth
phenomenon again both
the glycolytic intermediates and the tca
cycle intermediates funnel into
biosynthetic pathways from lipogenic
pathways to nucleotide pathways and so
the way we like to think is that the
both set of metabolites
the glycolytic metabolites as well as
the t-cell cycle metabolites
are necessary uh for tumor growth
we don't think either pathway is
sufficient but they're both necessary
and i think that's sort of the
simple take-home message and of course
one of the exciting things is trying to
find ways to
target certain enzymes in these pathways
and combine it with chemotherapy or
radiotherapy
as well as immunotherapy and see if
we can find the metabolic therapies uh
for cancer therapy so
let me switch gears um in my second half
here and talk about neurodegeneration
and you know how do we get into this
obviously i'm not a neurobiologist
um and and the way we got into is um
i'll just uh show you it
really came from our cancer metabolism
work so one of the other reasons we've
i've always been interested in uh
neurobiology is and i
once in a while get invited to a
neuromeeting just to broadly talk about
mitochondria is that
you know one of if you ask the neuro
community
as to why any particular neurological
disease is
obviously one of the the leading
theories is
and proteotoxicity so many of the
neurological diseases have
protein aberrations or protein
misfolding
but the other mechanism people
talk about and which is not mutually
exclusive to the proteotoxicity idea
that mitochondria are dysfunctional
and this and canonical explanations as
to how mitochondrial dysfunction leads
to neural
any neurological disease is too much ros
right too much too much reactive oxygen
species which clearly at high levels can
damage
or bioenergetics right i mean the brain
is a metabolically active organelle
and synaptic transmission is an atp
demanding process and
uh you know glycolysis is
atp is insufficient for neuronal health
so simple idea too much raws too little
atp
and so i want to present a third idea
which is uh
not mutually exclusive it's the idea of
metabolic toxicity what if
mitochondria when they're dysfunctional
make a neurotoxic molecule and i want to
talk about one in particular
that we're excited about is called l2
hydroxyglutarate
which might be linked to neurological
diseases
so how did we stumble upon l2 hydroxy
glutamate
and so again going back to our our tumor
experiment so remember i showed you this
143b
cell line which has a mutation in
complex
three so this mutation in complex three
uh obviously these cells don't grow in
vivo but in vitro as i pointed out and
we've been playing with these cells for
now
like 16 17 years in the lab for a
variety of reasons and many
graduate students and postdocs have used
this as sort of our
electron deficient tumor cell line to
play around for a variety of reasons i'm
thankful to carlos mores who
kindly gave me this cell line it's been
a
really a wonderful cell line and we did
a lot of experiments in vitro
in fact one of the things we did was uh
team up with ralph deborah denis years
ago and gave ralph
the cell line and i think this is uh
ralph told me this was one of his first
metabolite profiling experiments they
did and i think he likes the cell line
because
compared to the wild type you know you
have a complex three deficiency
well and if you're just setting up a
mass spec
uh profiling a metabolite profiling you
want
sort of a robust system where you have
an on off switch almost so you have
wild-type cells
or you have complex three naka so you
should see massive changes in metabolism
which
you know if you're sort of trying to
perfect your metabolite profiling it
would be a good use
and the top metabolite that was uh um
that was elevated in these complex three
obviously succinate which is
comes from complex two but it was this
two hydroxy glutarate
right and uh and we reported this in the
cell reports paper it didn't really
make much off it didn't necessarily
highlight it but it's there
in this paper but you know it always
stayed with me and we're doing some
other experiments so what is two
hydroxyl glutamate i think
most of you know about two hydroxy
glutarate and the lion's share of two
hydroxyl glutamate's attention
comes from uh it's linked to these idh
mutations sort of the darling of the
cancer metabolism field for the last 15
years and there's drugs against these
mutations
that argios has now and these are linked
to aml
glioma and other cancers and just to
remind you
so these um mutations in idh will make
the
d form of two hydroxy glutamate but
there's another
form called the l form or sometimes the
s form as it's called so but l2
hydroxide glutamate is made when nadh
levels are high
and it's not made by mutations in adh
but they're actually
made by malay dehydrogenase
or lactate dehydrogenase there's an
enzyme that can get rid of l2hg
called l2h gdh and they'll convert it
back to alpha-ketoglutarate
and really the l2hg is the
more widely um
you know the more widely recognized
metabolite throughout evolution so e
coli can make l2hg
um plants can make it the mammalian
cells make it
uh you can always make it as long as you
have uh this
build up of nadh and so let me um
show you a little bit of the chemistry
of these reactions
and really the take home is the d
the d form of 2ag largely is made with
idh mutations it can also be made other
ways but
the the really the accumulation is due
to the idh mutations and what i'm
referring to today is the
l form of it the l2 hg and this
accumulates when nadh and nad
are increased of course as you know the
nadh nad ratio would increase because
complex one wouldn't work right because
complex one regenerates nad
and so uh and that's how we sort of
started to link it because a complex one
regenerates nad and so mitochondrial
dysfunction is known to increase nadh
levels and that would be predicted in
some cases than to elevate
l2 hydroxyl glutarate so
malay dehydrogenase 2 typically
takes mallet as a substrate but
promiscuously it will use
alpha-ketoglutarate
only when nadh is around and generate l2
hg
l2hg can be converted back to
alpha-ketoglutarate in the mitochondria
by a l2
hgdh in the cytoplasm malay
dehydrogenase
1 or ldh will also convert alpha
ketoglutarate
to l2hg acidic ph can make this reaction
go
and the l2ag can sort of equilibrate
between the mitochondria and the
cytoplasm but
again i've highlighted this in blue it's
really important to think
that what's driving these reactions are
really normal enzymes malay
dehydrogenase lactic dehydrogenase and
normal metabolite alpha ketoglutarate
but it's happening under conditions
which are a bit abnormal when you have
high levels of nadh due to mito
dysfunction
one place naturally this would happen is
when nadh
accumulates in severe hypoxia and
hypoxia is known to increase l2hg
we clearly found l2hg markedly
elevated in our mitochondrial complex 3
null
cell line or cytochrome beneal cell line
then the other reasons i'm excited about
metabolites you know
in a metabolic profiling depending on
your particular core
you know at least they do 200 250 some
do 400
targeted metabolites one of the
challenges of all these metabolites
is to think in the context of larger
biology like
why is any of these metabolites
interesting why is two hydroxyl
glutamate interesting
for us two hydroxyl glutamate is super
interesting not only is it linked to
high levels of nadh which would happen
when mitochondria are not functional
but also what they do and what they do
is they're potent
inhibitors of alpha-ketoglutarate
dependent dioxygenases
as and these alpha cuda glutara
dioxygenases include
the prolial hydroxylases that control
hips
as the tet enzymes that control dna
methylases
the rna-d methylases enzymes the jumanji
domain
histone d-methylases they're all
inhibited by
like succinate but also by two hydroxyl
glutamate both the ln
and the d-form all right so when you
have this accumulation of two hydroxyl
glutamate the l-form compared to alpha
ketoglutarate you'll see histones
being hypermethylated dna being
hypermethylated rna being hypomethylated
you'll see hef being stabilized
is and so that's quite exciting because
all of those processes control cell
function and
cell fate and in fact indeed elena also
in the lab
she was interested in studying
hematopoietic stem cells and uh
as you know hematopoietic stem cells
have to self renew but they also
differentiate into multi-potent
progenitors
and in mitochondria are dysfunctional if
you lose complex three
in stem cells and we can do this
genetically in vivo with all the genetic
tricks
uh what elena noticed was that there's a
lot of l2 hydroxy accumulation in these
stem cells
and this prevents their differentiation
into multiple progenitors
sam weinberger last year reported that
the regulatory t
cells so again if you knock out complex
three
specifically in regulatory t cells
remarkably
the regulatory t cells are there there
are tons and numbers they survive
they find a way to grow probably through
reductive carboxylation
they use glycolysis for atp
but because of the high cumulation of l2
hydroxy glutarate
uh they just don't do what they're
supposed to do which is their
suppressive function right so regulatory
t
cell's main role is to prevent
inflammation and an effector function so
if you lose complex three
the t-rex are there but they don't
suppress
inflammation and these mice develop a
lethal autoimmunity and die within
a few weeks after birth and again these
t
rags these complex three deficient t
regs have high levels of
l-to-hydroxyglutarate and they have high
levels of dna hypermethylation
which is known to be linked to a
diminished
suppressive function in rex
one interesting thing that caught our
attention was that the enzyme that gets
rid of uh 200 l2 hydroxyl glutamate is
called
l2 hgdh now
there are unfortunately humans that have
mutations in that
scavenger enzyme and so these
uh people are born and
and then they develop a variety of
neurological
disorders it's a very very rare mutation
they're only probably you know a couple
of hundred people in the world
but you can detect l2 hydroxy glutamate
l2ag levels in the urine plasma
or cs of these patients they have
cerebral atexia and they have epilepsy
they have a variety of neurological
manifestations there's high levels of
l2e gdh normally in the brain
so clearly there's some nadh imbalance
always in the brain and making some l to
a g
luckily we all have this enzyme that
gets rid of l2ag
levels because if you don't get rid of
it if you have this mutation then
l2ag is clearly a neurotoxic
and what this uh terrible human
experiment essentially tells you
uh is these l2ag sufficient to cause
uh neurological disorders
and so uh i want to just uh pause for a
second and uh again i'm thankful to
david and the folks at agilent for this
webinar and i think these webinars
through zoom and other technologies i
don't think this was boom this is what
lab roots you know they're serving um
uh i think this is a great service in
disseminating
up-to-date information in a particular
field and you know
um as a boy i used to live in the
himalayas and so
uh as a kid and i'm sure people in the
himalayas i know have a
um internet service and you could just
plug in and watch
this and and i know there's a move to
have more and more webinars and i think
this is great there's a sort of a
democratization of of information and i
love it
however there's also a move where people
think well is there any value of
meetings and i'm going to tell you
unequivocally that small meetings are of
great great great value and i'll tell
you
in my career all the major things we've
done have come out of my discussions at
small meetings
and small meeting anywhere from 50 100
200 maybe 300 people
and so years ago i was invited to london
by a guy named joe bateman
i was born in london i love london as a
city i just showed up there
not knowing what to expect there's a
neurological meeting thought i'd learn a
few things check out london
and i one of the organizers was joe
bateman and i went and had a beer with
joe at
one of their local pubs and he was
telling me about some of his ongoing
research and he had just published this
really nice paper in pns
where he's got a model where he
overexpresses t-fam now
by over-expressing t-fam you get too
many mitochondrial dna
expressing proteins and you get sort of
a proteotoxicity
specifically in the neurons of these uh
flies so he uses the drosophila model
where you can do beautiful genetics and
do
quickly you can come to some conclusions
and these
as uh flies have a climbing beef i mean
just sitting over beer
as um we sketched out an interesting
experiment which was
you know could we test the causality of
l2 hydroxyglutarate
uh in his uh neuronal specific t-fam
model right so he's got a
quick model where he can generate flies
uh which have near degeneration
and he can get rid of l2hg and so what
he did is uh we hooked up with greg
mcelroy in my lab
and blindly he sent us fly brains
uh which overexpressed t-fam and greg
measured it using our metabolomics
facility here and clearly the brains of
these uh
flies have more to hydroxyl glutarate
and then what joe
and his uh the graduate students in lab
did were
uh rachel and lucy they over expressed
that same enzyme l2 hgdh
right if you overexpress that enzyme you
decrease
l2hg levels well then clearly you do and
so now the killer experiment is
is l2hg necessary for that climbing
defect
clearly it is right so again
the if you over express the enzyme
nothing bad happens but
if you take the t femme over expression
which clearly causes a climbing defect
you can see here in the blue
and those same flies if you over express
the l2 hgd ghd
gdh uh it's mislabeled here
it decreases the l2eg levels
and now the flies can distance climb
they fly away
right we've rescued it and there's a
beautiful simple genetic experiment
and uh that says that at least in flies
in this one
model all the the climbing defend the
neurological
defects causing this climbing defect are
due to
the accumulation of l2a gm again we
didn't fix the atp
or the ross or anything else we just
fixed the l2ag problem
and we largely uh cured the mice we're
doing a similar experiment in mice
uh and it'll be quite exciting to see if
l2ags
in certain contexts is a missing link of
how
mitochondrial dysfunction causes
neurological diseases
i just want to show one simple
experiment we've been
we've been doing in in uh uh that we
just did
is uh uh while the l to a gdh experiment
is going
in mice one of the other things we've
been interested in is looking at the
role of complex one
and its role in nad regeneration again
the way we're doing it is similar to
what we've done with ax and lb knox we
generated a mouse
where we can get rid of complex one and
put back ndi1 on ndi1
and will regenerate nad just to remind
you
complex one proton pumps
it generates superoxide it will
regenerate nad
you can get rid of complex one and
overexpress ndi1 and you only bring
nad regeneration and and uh
greg mcelroy in my lab was interested in
the role of nad
regeneration distinct from other roles
of complex
one in proton production or superoxide
in the brain
colleen generated the ndi1 so this is a
yeast protein it's a single yeast
protein she made this lock stop locks
mouse and what the greg decided to do is
took a model of lee syndrome which is
linked to complex one mutation so this
is a complex one
loss of function of ngufs4
so remember mitochondrial complex one
has 45 subunits
if you lose in ufs4 you get a hypermorph
of complex one in the
and then specifically in the brain and
uh and they have all these
uh abnormalities and basically you use
nest increase so sort of
somewhat brain specific cree knocked out
complex one function by
uh ndfs4 and uh re-expressed ndi1
so we're asking whether ndi1 which is a
single yeast protein can complement the
loss
of a 45 subunit mammalian
and this just shows you it works so he
can isolate
cortical neurons and or astrocytes these
are cerebral
neurons actually um and uh he gives pure
sight and again using the sea
horse pure sighting is a complex one
inhibitor
o car levels go down with ndi1
they're completely rescued in the wild
type or in the conditional knockout
and we can do the same sort of
experiment in our conditional knockouts
so clearly
ndi1 works as predicted right so complex
you knock out ndfs4
which is a cko here old car
goes down a couple respiration goes down
you put back ndi1
it rescues it and this was a specular
experiment i thought
so these mice uh you know die around
base 60 or 70
and by putting back ndi1 it prolongs
their lifespan
and this is quite remarkable if you
think about it because
you're asking a single yeast protein to
bring back the function of 45 subunits
and make the brain
and uh work again essentially and i
think these enzymes like aox lb knox and
di1
uh you know trying to do this in vivos
uh these ancient metabolic enzymes it
can really help us dissect
you know what are the dominant functions
in different cases
of the respiratory chain is it all about
atp is it all about nad regeneration or
is it about ros
superoxide and h2o2 production or
something else
so these are going to be very helpful in
dissecting these functions going forward
and broadly in the last few minutes that
i have
i want to just touch upon this sort of
this general idea that we're
pursuing beyond l2hg you know which is
that if you think back about
any of these neurodegenerative diseases
parkinson's alzheimer's als
uh you know could the underlying uh
factor be
a metabolite toxicity uh yeah there's
quite a bit of evidence that metabolites
are toxic i mean there's a whole field
of inborn errors of metabolism
where children are unfortunately born
with mutations and metabolic
enzymes and that leads to either an
increase or a decrease
of a particular metabolite so think of
pku
uh as an example and so i've i borrowed
this from ralph deborah dennis's
excellent review and
jbc where he's just highlighting here
the tca cycle
enzymes right so any of these enzymes
whether it's alpha ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase ogdh or pdh
uh if there's mutations in these enzymes
you have
changes in all and particular
metabolites a pdh
lactic pyruvate ogdh
changes in two hydroxyl glutamate and
alpha-ketoglutarate and this leads to a
variety of
neurological pathology so again it tells
you
that changes in metabolites are
sufficient
to cause neurological pathologies in
other words metabolite toxicity is
sufficient
to give you neurological disorders the
question is
are they ever required for the many
other
neurological disorders such as
parkinson's als
or alzheimer's or other
diseases and i think this is an idea
worth thinking about because
if you look in the literature there's
quite a bit of data
that the proteotoxicity might be the
trigger
all right so you have a bearing
accumulation of uh aggregates
but eventually that might cause
organelle dysfunction right lysosomes er
mitochondrial and you know all roads
lead to mitochondria and typically
people think about
uh mitochondrial roths or atp
but could it be their metabolites
that get altered right you know
this is not to say that ross and atp
changes aren't important but a third way
to think about it might be
to think about metabolites and what's
nice is in many of these
[Music]
studies lysosomal dysfunction is a is a
hallmark of neurological dysfunction
there's a nice paper from one of our
colleagues in the
metabolism field kevon bursoy the
rockefeller
sort of paper in this year uh in
molecular cell
and uh and what they showed is when you
have lysosomal dysfunction this leads to
uh changes in iron which as you know
iron is important for iron sulfur
clusters of electron transport chain so
we've known that lysosome
or dysfunction can lead to mitochondrial
dysfunction
uh and and they provided a nice
mechanism here
and so what i'm trying to argue is you
know irrespective of what might be
driving it upstream lysosomal
dysfunction proteotoxicity
but downstream could it be that there's
metabo like dysfunction at the
mitochondrial level
oh and that leads to metabolite
dysregulation right
so in other words diseases like als
parkinson's
alzheimer's ultimately might cause
lysosomal dysfunction due to
proteotoxicity
or er dysfunction but eventually they
cause mitochondrial dysfunction
and this either causes an increase in a
pathogenic metabolite like l2 hydroxy
glutamate goes
and accumulates and accumulates and we
know that if l2hg accumulates too much
uh it'll cause neurological dysfunctions
or one of the major rules of
mitochondria is to make aspartate and
when mitochondria don't work
aspartate levels fall so physiological
metabolites like aspartate might be
falling there could be other metabolites
that are physiologically made
that fall when mitochondria don't work
as well as some pathogenic metabolites
that accumulate and then these
somehow maybe through epigenetics or
other gene expression changes
slowly drive this pathology and this is
sort of a broad idea now that we're
focused in the lab
and we'll just see how far this takes us
and
l2hg is one example of a pathogenic
metabolite but there could be many many
others
out there the most important slide i try
to mention some of the people in my
martinez race i've
recently finished the
cancer story i talked about colleen
resigned the ndi one nice that greg
mcelroy used to do the
ndi1 experiments in the brain that i
finished the talk with i'm grateful to
joe bateman now
you know we and rachel and lucy in their
lab it's been a great collaboration
um sort of envious that they can do
experiments a little bit faster than we
do in mice
uh with their uh uh quick drosophila
genetics and they've really given us
quite a bit of insight
and again i'm thankful to uh
david and agilent and uh lab roots as
well for uh hosting this
webinar thank you
all right now uh that was great that was
a great journey i really appreciated
that so that the audience uh
in fact so much so pretty sure guarantee
we won't get through all the questions
so let's go ahead and
uh dive into them so um i think you
ended
the lecture very nicely with i think one
of the more
cogent uh explanations of what chronic
disease might be all about and how it
actually
goes through that cycle and you know
it's it's not the genes you're born with
that necessarily dictates it it may be
predisposing but
i know what's really nice is that you
get some kind of stress
it may be acute but if it's a lifestyle
that you continue like nutrition
or a bad lifestyle or smoke whatever
that is
though because the energetic system is
always in balance it creates a new
normal that goes down that slippery
slope that you're describing and they
explain why it takes many years
so really the question here is um
is is when you get these acute absences
proteotoxicities these other things can
affect
is that at first an atp decline or is it
a redox or
some kind of appropriate shuffling that
doesn't get you to a fully
efficient equilibrium where everything
kind of is in balance or
is it too much of a chicken and an egg
that you know you can't really separate
out what's kind of the first
kind of um chronic hit that kind of
forces the system into a new equilibrium
that's not nearly as healthy or let's
say is
physiologic
right um so two to two quick uh answers
the first one is thank you for uh
bringing this idea of a slow
accumulation of a metabolite right many
diseases we know these chronic diseases
as there's a slow
uh sort of a slow lag time until
uh symptoms manifest themselves and
benefits are age related
there's a time scale to it and that's
exactly why we're interested because
something like l2ag is probably a normal
metabolite
uh that does come during hypoxia
transiently goes up and it has a normal
function i
i there's some data in drosophila to
suggest it's a developmental signal
but the idea is chronic stress we
think would cause chronic elevation of
nadh
as you know one of the things that
people are thinking about is taking nad
supplements to restore that imbalance of
nadh to nad
and having that chronic nadh levels be
high
slowly triggers l2hg so remember the
mechanism by which l2hg is made is
through these normal
malady hydrogenous enzymes or lactic
dehydrogenases that are taking nadh but
that's a slow occurring
reaction and then slowly as the nadh
levels continue to be
persistently high l2 ag slowly slowly
slowly accumulates
and gets to a threshold where it's
pathogenic
right and so i think it's the key is
um the nadh build up slowly and that
slowly then
triggers uh 2hg for this chronic
conditions that uh that you're referring
to
and you kind of led to a pretty popular
follow-up question
uh you you dive into it too much is that
would for example supplementation of nad
externally
and way this question was asked one of
them was would that yield tumor growth
instead of just lb knox for example but
but kind of the broader question
is external energy going to influence
this balance in any way
right right um we have
not in our own studies with nad
uh uh nmn and our stuff more within and
then we've done
uh we have not necessarily observed
a dramatic effect in proliferating cells
with the external nad
supplements and so where we have
uh seen and other people have better
data on this in
tissues that are post mitotic so the
brain
and the muscle the heart when you do
give back nad you can start to see that
ratio
change the nadh to nad ratio being
restored and and so where i am sort of
interested
uh under what conditions nad supplements
would
restore the nadh nad imbalance and
restore
the l28g levels back to normal in
proliferating cells
tumors really even in t cells we haven't
seen
a dramatic effect in our hands but i
think i'm very open to the possibility
that in post-mitotic cells uh
giving these things work and i think
there's quite a bit of data to suggest
that in the literature
right right and as you can see here i'm
trying to combine as many questions
let's keep going here um the other one
which kind of comes back to your initial
i think really good explanation and kind
of walking through
this kind of um yin and yang of
oxidative and you know anaerobic
glycolysis
and uh so the straightforward question
i'll just add to a little bit is that
you know in your complex one knockouts
there's no atp
production so how does glycolysis
respond but i'll take it a step
further is are they completely capable
of of compensating for each other or
is there something also qualitatively
differently so even though it may appear
over a certain period that there is
appropriate compensation
is it really the same thing so you know
maybe you'll first you know conflict
with knockouts
kind of what happens glycolysis and then
definitely is it an
even one-to-one thing or is there
something more to it
yes so so one of the things that
um we've known from many of our in vitro
studies is that if we knock out complex
one or complex three in vitro
uh clearly the cells can proliferate and
they can
proliferate at quite a rapid
speed which which means you know not as
good as the wild types which means that
glycolysis
is sufficient to generate enough atp for
to drive
the metabolic demands in our experiments
what was surprising was when we knocked
out complex one glycolysis clearly goes
up and
it does all of the atp burden now
and if we put back the mito lb nox it's
in
vivo uh putting back the mito lb nox you
regenerate the nad but
they're still purely glycolytic because
the miter lb knox doesn't contribute to
atp production right
so now in vivo they grow great right
which means that in v way even
glycolytic atp is enough to full growth
right you don't need mitochondrial atp
under lisa
you know again i don't know how
universal this is obviously but under
these conditions
it's all glycolytic atp driving uh
the tumor growth and it's really the nad
regeneration that's quite important from
the etc
that's also necessary for the tumor bro
well our time is up my friend uh but i
think you were able to at least address
some about the higher level
uh questions i really appreciate the
audience i mean they were following this
and as you can tell from some of the
questions
uh we're really getting a lot of what
was going on and i think it was
extremely helpful so
now thank you so much for joining this
event and sharing your findings with us
and i appreciate the audience's
attention as well so thank you everyone
great thanks a lot david